foreign
[Music]
ERS in various domains and profiles I
got confused where I am heading towards
and what I am going to do next so I
started doing research and found out
that product management is the one which
will meet my career goals hi I'm
vasudevan I'm working as an associate
product manager in mobix Labs I got this
job with over 50 percentage of hike
after completing the certification I
completed my bachelor's in 2010 and I
landed my first job immediately after
that I worked in various sectors like
Telecom customer support and ID I
started my own business in 2019 under
shutdown in 2021 after feeling stuck I
decided to upskill with the professional
product management certification offered
by SP joint association with simply
learn I did my research about the
companies looking for product managers
and I found out the curriculum matches
the requirement of the job the SP Jones
brand name make me to join this course I
really like the course structure which
is
I have gained in-depth knowledge in
subjects like value proposition canvas
and how to build MVP the last session
was really fruitful and we have learned
lots of ideas and how to come up with
different ideas and solutions how offer
to the course I started sending my CV to
the companies who are looking for
product managers and I landed this job
as an associate product manager with
mobix Labs with over 50 percentage of
salary hike I am using the learnings
from the course things like agile and
prioritization techniques and also I am
working with two different products
right now that I am using these
techniques to craft the requirement of
the product and also building the road
maps even this course brought me closer
to my long-term goal of owning a product
and I started working on my products in
my spare times I believe dreaming big is
important but only dreaming is not
enough dreams only come true when you
work hard to achieve them